i thought about food all day because i  was hungry you're not you're bored like  if you're like oh man i could go for a  chicken breast you're hungry if you're  like oh i could like go for a snack  you're bored i don't know it felt like  hunger but yeah of course you don't know  the difference yeah i don't know the  difference i don't know that if you  learn the difference when you're really  hungry you're like chicken sounds great  like an apple sounds delicious when  you're bored you're like i could go for  some chips if you could go for a chicken  breast that's dry with no sauce that's  when you're hungry i was convinced that  i was hungry all the time but now that  you said that i don't think i was hungry  the dead space where you would normally  reach for your phone it's like well i  may as well just eat a quick snack i  just had like an epiphany i think i  don't know the difference between being  hungry and being bored